so the pass is going to come from rivers
the right isn't right in front of us to
Abdul Rahman at midcourt extra pass
[Applause]
a freshman has won it for the Wolverines
[Applause]
Michigan
[Applause]
a prayer at the buzzer and the prayers
answered here's how it came down they're
all executed tremendous packs and enough
time to make the extra pass at the
buzzer sideline a couple bounces and in
time the celebration begins a freshman
who hadn't scored in the second half
until right there an absolute slugfest
with a dramatic finish Poole just lines
it up that's defended well by Corey
Davis he's got the high ends just
destiny on the Wolverines side the
officials are over there taking a look
but we already know what both teams that
haven't cleared the court do know that
was good well go all the way back to
vogner's timeout and then the
well-designed play by John Beilein and
without pressure on the ball
Houston this Michigan was able to throw
that baseball pass as the three
officials with security guards are
running them head to the locker room
there was no doubt I mean Corey Davis
arrives on time of catch has high hands
on that shot and just delivers and you
know what lather this was somewhere else
during the course of the game that
probably would have been a free throw to
follow I think he was fouled on the shot
much less now he hits the biggest shot
of his young career
and the celebration carried him a whole
lap around all 94 feet of the court and
there's the feeling of the Cougars who
thought they had a sweet 16 matchup but
not its third seeded mission